what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with Phoenix
resurrection the return of Jean Grey
like a quick little story myself and
Binney were at actually myself Benny and
Gary the camera guy were at Emerald City
Comic Con and it's funny because Benny
got me all these like variant covers for
Phoenix resurrection and I was like dude
that's so cool but like like initially I
was like man I mean that's so that's
that's a pretty hefty gift you know in
in binney's determination like comic
stories determination for whether or not
I buy something wasn't all like a gift
that he gives me is if I would buy it on
my own and if at any point I say I mean
I would definitely buy that then he's
like cool I'll get it for you and like
that's that's it like we did that back
and forth like I'll buy him stuff back
and forth which I have a really cool
gift in mind to repay him for getting me
that because that was a pretty a pretty
hefty gift and I'm pretty sure he'll
like the one that I'm giving him but
Phoenix resurrection is an amazing story
because when it comes to stories like
this this is designed to hit a couple
different marks this is about as close
as Marvel has gotten to like a rebirth
esque kind of thing and the sense that
it hits the mark of like classic x-men
fans and it hits the mark of like new
x-men fans because for a lot of new
x-men fans they don't really know
original Jean Grey they know like all
new Jean Grey from businesses run the
younger version that was brought to the
present from the past but they don't
really know like classic dark Phoenix
Phoenix saga Jean Grey you know that's
kind of a kind of not really a mystery
so much is like an age of comics they're
not really a part of it anymore and so
this is cool because it creates a bit of
nostalgia for those of us who have been
reading for a long time at least for me
it does but initially this opens up with
a young girl who's just laying dead in
the street like I'm just literally
bleeding from the head and her eyes are
gone and this she just kind of stands up
and then starts talking backwards it's
crazy because what she says is we were
better off dead and like that's wild
like it's really kind of interesting to
see that because for those of you guys
who are familiar with Jean Grey's
history this looks remarkably like that
like the girl of Jean Grey though the
friend of Jean Grey who died when she
was younger and that's what this is
designed to be it's designed to hit all
these different marks this girl subtly
rises up this girl started to see male
kind of speaking to them and then you
sort of cut to the x-men showing up
about two hours later where the
sheriff's are basically contacted them
over the fact that a lot of this is kind
of weird now there are a couple things
that I want you to bear in mind here the
first is that Rachel summers nose starts
bleeding and that's huge because when it
comes to like psychic beings in Marvel
Comics one of the ways in which Marvel
will often on indicate how powerful a
being is is they can have like kind of a
residual impact on another psychic
person another person with telepathy or
telekinesis or something like that
nosebleeds are kind of the way they do
it you don't see
all the time you kind of have to take it
for what it's worth but in this moment
it's basically designed the show that
like there's a pretty powerful presence
here now the two kids who were there and
witnessed this young girl they're
basically collapsing and sort of out of
it and so what this does is it brings
together this this massive meeting of
like all the x-men related teams
basically x-men gold x-men blue whatever
other members of the x-men are out there
they don't really part of a particular
team but the question that people have
is what's going on here in the sense
that like there's some unusual residual
energy being found but it's actually
being found in various locations one of
the things I find is that is in the
heart of Midtown that is basically in
Manhattan there's no spot words in Mont
Saint Francis the monastery on the south
side of France Yale and that is on the
North Pole now those are the guys who
are familiar with Jean Grey's history
you know that these have very particular
moments when it comes to like her life
and times now they all have very
particular reasons for like why these
things happen we'll get we'll cross that
bridge once we get there because there's
a few more locations that are gonna pop
up as things go on the problem with this
is that nobody really understands what
it is that's happening nobody really
grasped what it is is taking place here
the only thing they really know is that
for some reason or another
basically Phoenix energy is being picked
up and they can't really grasp why now
as to why these locations matter when it
comes to basically Midtown that's the
former location of the Hellfire Club
this matters because of the fact that
while the Hellfire Club is basically
defunct meaning that all of its top
members Sebastian Shaw people like that
are basically in hiding and Emma Frost
is still kind of considered to be a
villain to a degree of the x-men this is
significant because this was the point
where by Jean Grey as the Phoenix was
transformed into the Dark Phoenix when
she was basically taken by jason
wyngarde and he used his powers to
effectively manipulate her mind and turn
her into a villain of sorts mont st.
francis that ties into the Phalanx
covenant that dealt with like Cameron
Hodge and things like that those you
guys who don't know the family's
covenant is like a story that started
like x-men I think it was uncanny x-men
316 and it ran for you like three basic
story arcs there was like Generation
Next and then a couple others I can't
remember what they were off to how my
head it's been so long but it was
basically a story where like the
failings covenant invaded earth and
tried to take over everything they
basically took over a few members of the
x-men's like you know close friends and
so on and so forth but it was a pretty
notable moment in the history of the
x-men the North Pole if I remember
correctly our is is the center point for
the events of Phoenix in song or Phoenix
war song but the idea is that with the
x-men showing up in these locations
where they basically start encountering
our
like constructs basically beings who
have long since been dead existing in
various forms different things like that
but they all start facing off against
the xmin for example in the Hellfire
Club it's the Hellfire clubs foot
soldiers inside of mont saint francis
they faced off against Seamus Mellencamp
I think it is Seamus Mellencamp was
actually kind of a weird guy he had the
ability to drain life for us uh but he
was a muse like a Morlock to a degree I
so again like it's just these little
things these little little tidbits here
and there various characters but the
idea of like classic Wolverine returning
as a construct sees him facing off
against old man Logan so it's actually
pretty cool now they end pretty fast
but what this does is it kind of
signifies so there's like this massive
phoenix in the sky basically meaning
like the phoenix force is returning and
so what we end up doing is picking up
out in the middle of nowhere with jean
grey and it's kind of wild because this
girl is just sort of there and just kind
of working you know what we also end up
finding out is that there's a guy who's
eating at this diner named cassidy now
this is this is mr. Cassidy this is
banshee banshees been dead for years and
so it's kind of crazy because basically
what it looks like is people who have
long since been dead are coming back to
life and that's why this is so cool ace
is written so incredibly well not only
this girl Jean when she goes home her
parents are there like her life is
basically the same way it was before
only for us to find out that she
actually has a date tonight or at least
it seems like she has a date and she's
met by Cyclops so again this is crazy
it's it's so cool and it's one of the
best stories that that Marvel's polished
in a long long time the issue with this
is that we end up switching over you
know a little bit to jeans personal life
and this is kind of cool because her
life is exactly what we would expect it
to be it's quaint it's it's basic it's
like Heartland America you know that was
really kind of life that she lived with
it was really kind of like a carefree
suburban life didn't really have a whole
lot to worry about now of course all
that changed when her powers kicked in
and she was brought in you know brought
him to the fold by by Charles Xavier but
still you know switching over to the
x-men there's all these different things
that are going on with regards to like
this Phoenix persona up hearing with
like these constructs that are being
manifested by some unknown being you
have guys like cable who are here and
that's a pretty big moment because when
you have guys like cable what it means
is that things are popping off pretty
significantly now cable being here
serves the purpose of being able to
access cerebro because remember for the
most part not many people can do this
and Rachel summers is currently out like
she's basically just sort of collapsed
so cables the only one they can really
go to for this now the problem is that
as soon as cable taps into cerebro and
as soon as cable tries to basically
analyze this energy signature that
exists out there
mind essentially shuts down like he's
basically just taken out entirely so
it's kind of wild to see this happen
because again we're dealing with a
massive amount of psychic energy that's
going on here the other half of this is
that with the x-men kind of
investigating as best they can and
figuring out what's going on we start
going into other things we start finding
out there are more energy signatures
that are taking place the Savage Land in
Antarctica the New York sewers in
Manhattan the ruins of Genosha Jamaica
Bay all these have significant moments
in the life and times of Jean Grey Jean
Grey's death at the hands of magneto in
new x-men if I remember took place in
Genosha the events of Jamaica Bay that's
what we found out that the Phoenix as it
was with Jean Grey was not actually Jean
that when Jean bonded with the Phoenix
force the Phoenix actually copied her
DNA entirely duplicated her and then
placed her body in the butt and the
bottom of Jamaica Bay to keep her safe
all these things have significant
moments in the life in times of Jean
Grey now while x-23 steam is examining
one of these locations alongside long
shot I'm pretty sure magneto suddenly
appears now this is not Magneto as we
know him this is classic Magneto and you
can tell by the get up by the outfit
that he's wearing is really just classic
Magneto's outfit but it is kind of
interesting because while they're
fighting against magneto he suddenly
starts rambling off all these
nonsensical things you know may I get a
fresh cup of coffee just different
things like that but there was a point
where by in this town that Jean Grey was
living in that magneto basically Erik
Lehnsherr had walked in and said the
exact same thing can I get a fresh cup
when you have a moment and so it almost
seems like Jean Grey is subconsciously
manifesting all these constructs and
just sending them out there into the
world we don't necessarily know exactly
what's going on with all this all we
know is that things are kind of running
amuck now the other half of this is that
it almost seems like this is kind of a
mind game of Jean Grey because while
this is happening suddenly like the
Phoenix emerges in the background of
this town she's living in and like
everything's going to pieces and like
it's all burning up and it's all sitting
on fire and everything is kind of coming
to an end and then she's just sort of
ignoring it she's it's kind of like
whatever you know like there's there's
nothing going on here there's really
nothing there the other half of this is
that as we start to get a little bit
more of a tour of the places that she's
living in we end up finding out that
there's a guy named mr. patch who's
basically wolf rain and it's kind of
weird because we know like historically
speaking when it comes to like Jean Grey
and wool rain that classic Wolverine
always had a thing for Jean and it
created kind of a love triangle sort of
this soap opera mentality that Chris
Clement was always shooting for when you
had Cyclops and you had Jean who were
together
Wolverine who was almost like the third
wheel but Jean Grey still kind of liked
him a little bit and it was always that
question of like who will she choose
Cyclops your Wolverine ultimately of
course she chose Cyclops but the fact
remains that in this scenario he
actually ends up trying to make a
movement on a move on her and actually
pushing her approaching himself onto her
now of course she kind of lashes out
using telekinesis not realizing what it
is that she's doing but still things are
pretty wild here and so what we end up
doing is picking up with the x-men and
basically joining up with Emma Frost now
Emma Frost and her team have actually
had a run-in with the Phoenix in the
Jean Grey solo series which is okay
there's basically a point where like the
Phoenix entity returns and then
essentially like takes out the entirety
of like Emma Frost and like quinton
choir and all these really powerful
telepaths it's actually one of the
reasons why Rachel summers is out is
because she'd responded to that and she
was taken out just like everybody else
it's not really an essential read but
again basically Emma Frost knows that
like Jean Grey is alive that Jean Grey
is in New Mexico that the Phoenix force
is around that basically everything
that's happening right now is happening
because of Jean and that's when we end
up switching back to Jean herself and
she's basically met with like her
Phoenix persona and that's kind of what
it seemed to be taking place here is you
know you have Jean the person who's
living in this you know whatever this is
and then you have like the Phoenix
persona that's trying to rebonds kind of
cool because it hits back to like all
those early things now again switching
back over with the x-men team this is
like a who's who this is basically
everybody who's involved with the x-men
or has been involved with the x-men and
even so far as x-factor like strong guy
anyone who has ever been part of the
x-men universe or part of one of the
x-men teams is basically there but when
the group shows up to new mexico they in
defining this massive dome that's
sitting out there and that's when we
start to come to the realization that
this whole life that jean grace
fashioned for herself isn't real that
it's basically her using the Phoenix to
alter reality and make all these things
exist create basically create like a
self-contained world for herself now
again with like everything burning up
everything being on fire Jean Grey
doesn't seem to notice or care as far as
she concerned everything is normal it's
one of these things were like these
flames follow her everywhere she goes
but they're only real for whatever is
she's not looking at so like when she
looked at this guy that's riding by on a
bicycle you know behind her everything's
burning you know but when she looks
looks back at that guy everything's
normal so again it's kind of odd it
basically hits at this idea that there's
the reality and then there's what Jean
Grey perceives it to be so again this is
pretty pretty intriguing and SM is
pretty awesome here now of course once
the group starts to make their way into
this location they end up
seeing things as they really are whereby
everything's basically kind of burning
up and everything's basically being
destroyed by the powers of the Phoenix
now all these constructs were also being
manifested too but they end up finding
out or the place where Jean Grey is
working at this diner is called a nice
now again Annie was the name of Jean
Grey's friend that died in her childhood
Amy was basically the catalyst by which
Jean became the Phoenix the Phoenix
first took notice of Jean because of the
fact that Annie died when she was a
little girl she was involved in a
hit-and-run accident she was literally
killed and the result was that Jean let
out this psychic backlash Charles Xavier
picked it up and the Phoenix force
picked it up it was basically Annie
setting all these pieces in motion
setting all these things in motion and
that's why one of the people here the
closest friend Jean Grey has is Annie
Annie is still very much alive in this
reality that she's created it's like the
one regret Jean Grey has the one thing
that she wish had never happened that
her friend hadn't died and it's almost
an answer to the question what if Annie
hadn't died what would the world look
like now the other half of this is that
Jean doesn't see the x-men being there
she doesn't recognize than that because
as far as she's concerned there's
nothing going on outside of whatever it
is that she wants it to see meaning that
reality is basically made up of her own
mind now from here itself into the realm
of a lot of like haphazard guessing
because remember when it comes to the
Phoenix it's kind of contextual for
example what you had was like the
Phoenix 5 for example during like
Avengers vs. x-men the Phoenix 5 was
cool but like all five of those guys
basically possess the power to
manipulate reality they were just godly
beings but they just kind of existed on
earth and did some stuff with the full
unbridled power of the Phoenix one thing
to bear in mind is there's only one
Phoenix force but there is a host for
the Phoenix and every single universe
the Phoenix force is an Omni virtual
force the Phoenix force is designed to
represent the sum total of all life that
has ever currently does and will ever
exist in the multiverse not just the
universe that's why the Phoenix egg
played such a prominent role in Jonathan
Hickman secret Wars and the events of
Avengers and New Avengers because
there's only one Phoenix force in the
whole multiverse and so that's the idea
is that Jean Grey was the host for the
Phoenix in the main Marvel Universe but
like other people would be hosts for the
Phoenix and other universes but of all
the people who have ever been a host
Jean Grey was the most complete host she
was the best person suited to be the
host for the Phoenix and so the idea is
that where the x-men sit down and they
start looking at this while a lot of us
theoretical in reality if the Phoenix
chose to it would obliterate everybody
here wipe out the entirety of the planet
Earth probably even snuff out the
universe
if it wanted to the group basically has
to come to the realization that they're
dealing with a level of power that is
Nayan nepeta in a lot of different ways
that for the most part it can't be
easily taken down so what is up
happening is you have old man Logan who
walks into the diner and starts talking
to Jean Grey but where most of the x-men
wanted to walk in there and say hey look
Jean you have to wake up you have to
realize what's going on instead old man
Logan walks in there and basically
realizes the Jean is just terrified she
has no idea what's going on
she's a scared little girl and her mind
is exceedingly fragile because if Jean
is pushed in the wrong direction
she'll rebound with the Phoenix force
and then kill everyone and so old man
Logan actually plays it smart by going
in and saying hey look I know you're
terrified I know you're scared I know
you're unsure about what's going on but
that's because none of this stuff here
is real well he does kind of do what
most of the x-men would have done
there's a little more tact to it which
is kind of ironic when you think about
that with Wolverine Wolverines never had
tact Wolverines always been like okay
cool so there's a bad guy let's go kill
him snikt you know and that would really
be yet
oh man Logan in his experience in his
wisdom the years that he's been around
has learned that you can't solve every
problem by just running in with
adamantium claws and tearing it up but
the problem with this is that Amy kind
of speaks up and says you have to get
out of here now supposed to be here and
that's when old man Logan breaks into
his classic self and just kills her
basically just just takes out an E and
destroys our entirely and then what this
ends up doing is this basically ends up
like forcing Jean Grey to face the
reality of the situation because what
happens as a knee basically manifests
she essentially returns to life and
that's when Jean Grey has to face the
fact that none of this stuff is real now
that's when all of Jean Grey's memories
begin to sort of flow back and return to
her now these memories begin to return
by extension to the fact that she was
the Phoenix and the Phoenix kind of you
know harbors and holds all these
memories that's the reason why Jean Grey
seemingly never really seemed to know
what was going on is because the
memories of her what her life used to be
were held within the Phoenix but with
the two of them rebonding together
she basically returns as the Dark
Phoenix but it's kind of an inner
struggle because what is up happening as
Jean Grey's trying to cast the Phoenix
off so again this is very much a tribute
and very much sort of a throwback to the
old Chris Claremont stories to the idea
that like the Phoenix wants Jean Grey to
do something Jean Grey doesn't want to
there's this inner fight between the two
but the Phoenix uses them a myriad of
different devices to try to sway Jean
Grey her parents appear to her and
saying hey look everything here is real
you can have anything you want
embrace the Phoenix and the world can be
what you want it to be and that's true
with all the power of the Phoenix has
Jean Grey could just remake
if she wanted to and so what is up
happening as Jean Grey basically cast
him out and that essentially has this
heart-to-heart face-to-face conversation
with the Phoenix but the last little
weapon that Phoenix pulls out is
actually Cyclops himself where he
basically says look we can go back to
the way things used to be we can have
things the way they were before before
all of this happened before I died
before you died we can all go back to
the way things you know the way things
used to be but Jean Grey actually kills
him she actually says no this is not how
things are supposed to be I miss you I
love you but you're not supposed to be
here you're supposed to be dead and so
again it's pretty beautiful and it is
done pretty damn well
it's basically sitting down and saying
Jean Grey is as care - that's existed
for decades and yes she died you know
she died some eight years ago roughly a
marvel wants to bring her back but there
are aspects of Jean Grey's past that
Marvel has to reconcile with Cyclops is
dead and he basically has been since the
events of like Inhumans vs. x-men is
terrible of that story was like he'll
he's basically been dead since then and
so the result is that Cyclops can't
exists right now I mean I guess maybe
Jean Gregg could have brought him back
but it would have been too much it would
have been too much of a return too many
things coming back because what this
would have done in the eyes of fans is
it would have open the door that Jean
Grey would have just turned into a
retconning machine it makes things kind
of tragic with the idea that like well
it would make sense for Cyclops and Jean
to be together again and it would be a
throwback to old school fans at the end
of the day it's just too much and so
what is it happening as Jean basically
destroy Cyclops destroys his essence and
essentially tells the Phoenix look I
know you want to bond with me I know you
want us to be together but we can't it's
kind of funny because the Phoenix force
is almost being treated like an
ex-boyfriend and that's where the
Phoenix really kind of comes out and
just speaks directly to Jean and says do
you not understand we can transcend all
of this we can return to the way we were
as the white Phoenix of the crown we can
go back and we can do anything we can be
gods we can control all things in
existence the world can be whatever we
want it to be you'd have to deal with
you know all these crazy things that
were going on you can just go back to a
much simpler life when you were Marvel
Girl and you were part of the x-men team
and that was it you can do whatever you
want with this world that you live in
but jeans response is no that's not the
way things need to be that life
progresses life moves forward you can't
stay in the same place forever things
change and so what she ends up doing is
just kind of casting off the Phoenix
basically casting aside and returning
back to her previous self as Marvel Girl
the way she used to look back in the
1960s by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby but
with that being said guys
to bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come and explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob for you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
also Jesus this story so good I mean
it's one of those times right to you
guys like buy this thing I mean it's a
damn good story it's one of the stories
it'll kind of bridge into like whatever
Marvel's doing next the fresh start or
whatever that is and it actually leads
into x-men red which I'm really kind of
digging right now to be honest but it
it's cool so let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section and
that will catch you all later peace
[Music]